c'est une nouvelle ère pour les hôpitaux
de plaisir depuis lundi 18 décembre la
ville héberge officiellement le nouveau
bâtiment de l'hôpital gérontologique et
médico social ce bâtiment il est fait il
est consacré principalement à la
gériatrie et il permet de traiter les
personnes âgées en situation de
de fragilité en hospitalisation dans les
premier et deuxième étages que en
ambulatoire ici dans l'autre chaussée
moderne et fonctionnel l'objectif du
bâtiment faciliter le travail des aides
soignants au premier étage les postes de
soins peuvent accueillir 120 lits au rez
de chaussée le service de jour peut lui
prendre en charge une trentaine de
patients les élus ont fait acte de
présence gérard larcher joséphine
coleman berger l'occasion pour eux
d'exprimer les ambitions du centre
hospitalier mesurer aujourd'hui les plus
de 60 ans c'est 15 millions
bientôt 24 et donc des défis à relever
on passe dans le 21e siècle on est dans
un accompagnement du patient qui est
vraiment optimum 120 millions d'euros
c'est le coût de ce projet d'innovation
qui promet de ne pas s'arrêter là
puisque le centre hospitalier de jean
martin charcot et de l' hôpital
gérontologique et médico sociales vont
fusionner l'objectif de la fusion c'est
pas simplement de faire des économies
c'est d'apporter un meilleur service est
un service de qualité
il le fait par exemple il y est
l'équipement scanner et irm
c'est le symbole d'un service
supplémentaire
l'établissement deviendra ainsi le
deuxième centre hospitalier du sud des
yvelines derrière versailles
le rapprochement des hôpitaux prendra
effet dès le 1er janvier 2018